it's a quote of yours I want to ask you
about it is it yeah acting is easy
that's your quote from Tim Olyphant do
you really believe that
acting is easy they tell me what to say
they tell me what to wear
I just it's a piece of cake really stand
over there and say this here put this on
but you know what about like method
actors no no well as you know I am I am
very method so for me it's difficult but
I could be easy but for me I go deep did
you did you see that that Jim Carrey
documentary on Netflix where he's for
that Andy Kaufman movie where he was in
character 20 beside yeah disease in life
he's like in character 24 hours a day 7
days a week never breaks character I
watched that documentary in character
[Laughter]
really my character hated it your
character didn't like the character
thought it was just narcissistic and
pretentious he watched like 20 minutes
the only reason he didn't turn off
sooner is because he thought that Paul
Giamatti might hit this is your
character now yeah Jim Carrey in the
flames no credible known audible it's
too bad cuz I think I would have liked
it yeah yeah to give it a lot you watch
TV and just in character is that what
you do use a lot of your your a lot of
your life isn't care when you're an
artist Conan it's you know I mean this
is the life you examine me you don't
mean I'm like Mozart over here and that
I will die young
[Applause]
you